hello and welcome to the agenda we're
here in the brussels hemi cycle now this
had a closed down a year ago due to
structural damage but as you can see
behind me the guys are putting the last
minute preparations ahead of next week's
mini plenary let's take a look at the
highlights across the two days
fallout from russia's annexation of
crimea hasn't just hurt diplomatic
relations with the west the standoff
could impact economies on both sides
it's anyone's guess what happens next
but europe is stepping in to help boost
ukraine's economy by removing 98 of
custom duties the trade committee has
already backed plans to save
manufacturers and exporters 487 million
euros it's now time for the full house
to back those plans the vote is expected
on thursday
iran is top of the agenda on day one the
eu has underlined the need for a more
constructive relationship after iran
signed up to a pack to kerber's nuclear
programme last year it wants to improve
bilateral relations with iran as well as
developing common grounds on fighting
terrorism human rights abuse as well as
encouraging iran to play a more decisive
role in regional politics can we soon
see an iranian envoy we'll find out more
when draft recommendations are put to
the test on wednesday
trying to find the best deal online or
perhaps you want to save for the future
well both are set to become a lot easier
under the telecoms package and the
portability of pension rights
under draft plans it will no longer
matter where your pension plan or your
mobile phone contract was drawn up
should you move to another member state
you can transfer your rights so no more
roaming charges and no more having to
draw up new plans for saving for a rainy
day
and finally on the same day as
parliament holds its mini plenary over
at the council there's going to be an eu
africa summit in preparation for that on
monday and tuesday the parliament along
with members of the pan-african
parliament will put together a joint
declaration to be presented at the
summit and so that's all we have for
this agenda take care and enjoy the week